la reina isabel deja su corona así como
una inmensa fortuna personal que incluye
numerosas propiedades
el castillo de balmoral en escocia está
valorado en 114 millones de euros la
casa de sandro en hama en inglaterra
vale 65 millones sus otros activos
incluyen prósperas tierras de cultivo un
amplio registro de acciones una
colección real de sellos obras de arte y
caballos de pura sangre
en total la fortuna de la reina se
estima en
436 millones de euros se espera que sus
hijos y nietos reciban su herencia pero
el reparto de sus bienes sigue siendo un
secreto ya que la familia real está
exenta de la ley que obliga a hacer
públicos los testamentos de los
ciudadanos británicos
saliendo de la reina isabel tiene vía
libre ciertamente tuvo cuidado con su
testamento porque era una mujer que
había planeado las cosas durante mucho
tiempo e hizo algunas provisiones para
su familia y quizás también regalos para
los amigos y para aquellos que
trabajaron para ella durante mucho
tiempo como forma de agradecimiento
lo que es cierto es que el patrimonio de
la monarca que incluye las joyas de la
corona pasa directamente al siguiente en
la línea de sucesión en este caso el rey
carlos tercero como rey carlos también
hereda el ducado de lancaster que le
proporciona unos ingresos anuales de
aproximadamente
27 millones de euros y por ley el
monarca el reino unido está exento de
pagar el impuesto sobre el patrimonio
esto significa que el rey carlos no
tendrá que pagar el impuesto de
sucesiones del país que es del 40 por
ciento lo que ayuda a mantener intactas
las posesiones de la familia real
mientras tanto como nuevo príncipe de
gales william área del antiguo título de
su padre y el ducado de con world lo que
le significaría unos ingresos anuales de
aproximadamente 24 millones de euros